[Music]
- thanks kami well is this one so on the
first thing sorry
our first hang the organizers for giving
me the opportunity to speak here
anything I'm gonna say is about my
personal opinion not that of my employer
and what I'm gonna talk about is this
joint project with a few people
including Brandon Evans who's there in
the audience who intern with us last
summer and as the title gives it away
I'm gonna talk about the privacy utility
trade-off which is something that
probably has come up in every talk we
heard until now and I'm gonna talk about
like a very like practical take on
balancing the privacy utility trade-off
I'm going to talk about the kind of
information about the privacy utility
trade-off that you need when you are in
a say in a team that's developing a
product or service that will be
potentially used sensitive data and for
for the purpose of this talk if you're
bothered by the utility word you can
think about something much more concrete
you can think about the error rate of a
machine learning classifier for example
so if you're trying to build a product
or service that will have this machine
learning part and that will have to deal
with potentially sensitive data usually
you might be part of a team that
contains scientists and engineers but
ultimately you're gonna have to interact
with a number of people you're gonna
have a number of conversations about
utility and about privacy to decide
wearing in the space of the trade-offs
you should see it
and and and when you want to have these
conversations you actually are going to
need very precise numbers so that these
conversations can be fruitful and you
can make informed decisions about
whether the system that you currently
has can find a point in this industry of
that satisfies the requirements in terms
of utility and privacy that you're gonna
have or whether you should go and try to
improve your system and then there might
be many ways to do that you can try to
design better algorithms you can
actually try to run the same algorithm
but collect more data it might be that
that maybe would you're not achieving a
good privacy ability trade-off because
your privacy knows is not tight so you
might try to go and get a tighter
analysis or you should also be have
enough data to decide that you should
give up and abandon this quest so so the
question is how are we going to do this
in practice and and and I want to start
by talking a little bit about the
distinction when we talk about the
privacy TDT trade-off between the theory
and the practical point of view so so my
background is machine learning theories
so when I initially started working in
differential privacy and I was thinking
about the privacy utility trade-off I
was thinking about things like this so
we're thinking about bounds that
hopefully will give us optimal rates and
will depend on the parameters of the
problem like the dimension of the data
the privacy parameters the NAM the
amount of records that we have but even
when you have this bounds and even when
we know that they're like optimal in the
sense of rates like these usually don't
give you enough information to have the
sort of conversations that you need to
have when you're like trying to put
something into production for example so
so things that might happen is that you
might not have explicit constants or you
might have explicit constants but the
constants are totally unrealistic or or
maybe the bounds are just worst-case
bounds but it so happens that in the
application or
like the particular data set or the
particular setting of your app that
you're trying to run your algorithm
maybe this bound is not exactly what it
should be so maybe I don't know maybe
the D should be a log d in the case that
I'm trying to to apply the algorithm to
maybe this one over N rate only kicks in
when n is on the order of millions and
maybe I don't have millions of data
points so so in in practice what you
want is information closer to these kind
of plots that John was showing yesterday
and then I shamelessly borrowed from his
presentation at the Cystic meeting in
December where where things are way more
concrete right so here we have like
privacy laws with actual numbers we have
accuracy with actual numbers and this is
the kind of information that we need in
order to make these decisions and and
and decide in which point we're gonna
operate on or or decide whether there's
no point that is good enough for us and
we need to go back to the to the
whiteboard and design a new algorithm or
collect more data or whatever is the
action we want to take now the one
problem arises when you try to get these
plots when Uranus in in particularly
machine learning applications where you
have algorithms connected when you have
algorithms like differentially private
stochastic gradient descent for example
right so Wolfer green did a great job at
introducing machine learning so I don't
have to talk too much about it but just
let me remind you that the stochastic
gradient descent is one of the basic
algorithms that you are gonna use in in
machine learning even when you don't
care about privacy and this is an
algorithm that is gonna like iterate
over your data set and at each iteration
we're gonna take a small sample of the
of the whole our dataset training data
set and we're gonna compute the
gradients on the current parameters on
the sub sample and we're gonna like
iterate over that to keep improving the
parameters now the the problem here is
that when
so when we try to privatize this
algorithm we make some changes so we for
example we clip the gradients we add
some Gaussian noise and so on so we end
up with algorithms that have a
relatively high number of hyper
parameters right for example in this
simple setting we always have five hyper
parameters we have the learning rate we
have the mini bite-size number of epochs
noise variance and clipping normal and
we know for example from from from
bacilli at all that well that theory
gives us a nice way to tune these hyper
parameters to achieve near optimal rates
in terms of some notion of utility when
the optimization is comebacks but in
practical applications these days people
use solve a lot of non convex problems
especially deep learning problems and in
this case we don't have good utility
boundary or utility bounds at all that
we can use to decide how we're going to
set up this hyper parameters and note
for example that here even if I didn't
care about the privacy utility trade-off
even if I just cared about like
achieving a fixed level of privacy
things are not as easy as they seem
because there's many ways in which I can
like play with the privacy of this
algorithm right so if for example I'm
interested in in getting more privacy I
can increase the level of noise I can
decrease the size of the minibar
I can decrease the clipping norm so how
should I like to decipher parameters
even if it just one like a fixed epsilon
I want the best utility so this is the
kind of questions that you need to be
able to answer if you want to put these
things into into production so what we
would really be interested in having our
plots like this which are very much like
John's plots but here in the y axis I
have error instead of accuracy for a
small technical reason that is not very
important but basically what we want is
to have this sort of Pareto France that
tell us for a given algorithm or a given
model or a given algorithm
model what is the the best a QC we can
get for a given epsilon and then ideally
like click on here and see what are the
hyper parameters that give you this sort
of trade-off and what would we would
like to do is be able to compute this
plot palatable efficiently and and here
is this is one of the problems with
machine learning so so to get just one
point in here you might need to train
one or more machine learning models and
when you're talking about deep learning
models this can take powers or even days
depending on the size of your training
dataset so we really want to like be
able to do this in in a reasonable time
so not evaluate the algorithm on like a
grid search over all possible hyper
parameters we also want to be able to do
this usually using measurements of
utility or empirical right because in
many cases we're not going to have
bounce to to get the utility and and and
finally what we would like to be able to
do with these plots is to enable
fine-grained comparisons like for
example in this experiment that we did
we took the emmys dataset and we try to
[Music]
multi-layer perceptrons so that they're
not they're neural networks are not very
deep but we like we tried two
architectures and we're trying to see
whether like one architecture is better
than the other in terms of achieving a
good privacy or utility trade-off and
and then we wanted to do that in in
reasonable time so the only reason that
I do it the other way is just one buy
extra classification is because
recognize it really that so that we do
the goal one sorry come again that
Pareto frontier ought to be convex is it
really not convex there doesn't need to
be come back some point on the goal and
some other parameter that's outside the
Pareto front units I'll show you another
illustration in a minute of how we build
the display the front that I think is
gonna answer your question but the
Pareto front doesn't need to be
comebacks I think it's just like
it's not coming back but that's okay
okay when I see that in one of these
applications
I assume the outliving messed up in the
rate in the region where it's not that's
okay
well we'll see when I explain how we do
that I'll have a slide about this at the
end yeah so for now what I'm gonna
assume is that I have utility or error
Oracle and I'm not gonna like try to
specify where this comes from right now
and then we'll talk a little bit about
it and and yeah there's gonna be like a
problem depending on how you measure the
error so just to like abstract a little
bit what we're trying to do we formalize
the this introducing parameterize class
of algorithms so these are all the
algorithm configurations that we're
going to try and lambda is the
configuration some hyper parameter space
and we assume that when we can when we
choose a setting for the hyper
parameters we can evaluate the error and
it's going to be a number between zero
and one so we have this error Oracle and
we also have a privacy Oracle that might
return a number between zero and
infinity and you can think for example
that this is epsilon for some things
Delta but you could also have other
things in there
okay so given this this objects what
we're really trying to do is we have
some hyper parameter space that might be
high dimensional might be like a bit
complicated in its geometry and we have
this two-dimensional plane of error
versus privacy loss and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna like successively like
pick hyper parameters that might be seem
interesting to us evaluate the error and
the privacy laws using the oracles and i
will give us a point in that plane and
we can repeat this over and over again
and at some point we get all these
points and we would like to build a
Pareto front that tells us that based on
the information we have seen so far
these are kind of the best
configurations right so the best
configurations will come and I hope this
clarifies your question by picking the
set of non dominated points which are
the points where we cannot improve say
we cannot decrease the error without
increasing privacy or the other way
around and and joining them by lines so
I don't see why it should be comebacks
from this picture it's for the basic
economics basically means you didn't
explore the parameter space insufficient
granularity to find a point between your
yellow and your green that's there that
dominates your red one but it could be
that it's like this right perfectly okay
if that's the best you can do that's
production possibility frontier because
okay so let's call this an empirical
Pareto frontier to get to this is my
teacher the drop this way to get to a
point that's closer to the origin in
your case by combining the algorithms
that gave you in this case the green and
the yellow it's not clear that there's
the convexity that like linear
combination property makes sense for one
thing also it depends on the scale of
the x-axis right if it's on the log
scale or something it like there's some
most elusive linearity of the Pareto
frontier and that was saying that this
is an empirical method for determining
sensible combinations okay so so the
point here is that this hyper parameter
space is huge so there's a lot of other
settings that we could try that are not
gonna give us Pareto optimal points so
in trying to determine this empirical
Pareto frontier what we would like is to
somehow efficiently explore the hyper
parameter space to find points that are
close to the trooper at the front and
ignore all the rest that's the right way
to define the exercise and when you
trying to find non convexity to that
Pareto frontier and suggest that the
exploration algorithm was insufficiently
granular that's what I'm trying to say
okay to beat monotone
because because it's not a little like
it because again these are two
parameters though very much depends on
the space of parameters in the subspace
of parameters like changing the
parameters might not actually improve
your utility and vice versa
for example of mixing two algorithms
with two different excellence only may
impose epsilon by just a tiny bit like
you know just mix like some parameters
are some measures of reports I think
that that's true when when the two
objectives are added up that you get
convex region but in here we're not
adding them up is either minimize the
error for a given privacy laws or
minimize the private privacy laws for a
given here the solution to one of those
two optimization problems describes the
frontier usually convex if this one's
about convex I would like to see the
proof I think it's compact yeah when
when when you sum the two objectives but
not all we can take this offline
so what we're gonna do to do that is use
Bayesian optimization so Bayesian
optimization is kind of a
well-established technique for
optimizing blackbox functions that are
expensive to evaluate so it's a whole
field of study and I'm just gonna give
you like the nutshell introduction and I
should also mention that is something
that is widely used in applications not
only for hyper parameter optimization in
machine learning systems but also in
many other places like scheduling and
planning for example airplanes when you
have like very expensive simulations to
evaluate each experiment experimental
design in chemistry and biology and so
on
so so the way the typical way Bayesian
optimization is formalized when you have
at least like one objective is that
you're given a function defined on on
some subset of a dimensional Euclidean
space you assume that this function is
expensive non convex and have some
degree of regularity and and what you
want to do is try to find this but just
doing evaluations like try to find this
minimum but just doing evaluations of F
so you don't have gradients for example
and and the way a Bayesian optimization
the works is is the following so we keep
track of K evaluations of the function
on lambda 1 lambda K points and using
this data we build the surrogate model
for F right so for example typical
Bayesian optimization would use a
Gaussian process for that and if you
don't know what the Russian process is
don't worry just think that what we're
doing is we have this few evaluations of
F and we're doing some interpolation in
the in the hyper parameter space and
this interpolation is probabilistic in
the sense that it doesn't only give us
like like some some shape F hat for F
but also gives us some degrees of
uncertainty around this this
interpolation and using these degrees of
uncertainty and means we will try to
find the most promising next evaluation
which typically involves like solving an
exploration exploitation dilemma
because so we're gonna have regions
where we haven't collected any
information because this hyper parameter
space might be really big and and and in
that case we might it's there's a
potential that the minimum that we're
looking at that we're trying to find is
in that region that we have an explored
and and we should like probably like
explored a little bit more but also when
we have indication that the minimum can
be around someplace
so we have a place where where this f
hat is relatively low we might want to
do some exploitation and try to do some
local search around that area to see if
we can improve that minimum a little bit
so if that didn't make any sense to you
let's let's do it again through an
example so this is a one dimensional
example of Bayesian optimization and the
goal here is to minimize this green
dotted line right that is this objective
function f that we don't know we just
have access to it through evaluation and
we want to find the minimum which is
going to be here see that ah well you
can see there in those other screens so
that so here we just evaluated the
function at least in one point and we
have the subrogate model that is this
black line that says well I just know
that the function here at 0.5 has this
value so I'm going to think maybe it's
just like flat but there's some
uncertainty around this flatness which
is which you can see in the other
screens and using this this mean and
this level of uncertainty we can derive
what's called an acquisition function
and the acquisition function in this
case is just the expected improvement
tells me for each point that I could
like pick next what is this the expected
improvement in the minimum that I can or
liked expected improvement in
information about the minimum that I can
get by picking a point so in this case
there's this red line here that says
well this is the maximum of the of the
acquisition function so you should
sample this point so that's what the
Bayesian optimization loop is gonna do
is gonna sample the function on that
point and since that is actually larger
than the
we have here and using these two points
now we have a new model and we have a
new uncertainty where you see that
around the point that we have sampled
already there's no uncertainty left
although if you just cancel with noise
you can also like incorporate that into
your model and now we're going to like
half using the new model a new
acquisition function now it's going to
decide to sample the other extreme of
the of the interval so when you iterate
this a couple of times you keep reducing
the uncertainty about your function
you're a kind of average function the
black line keeps getting closer and
closer to the green one and and the
points that the acquisition function
tells you to sample start to concentrate
around the minimum so here for example
in nine evolutions we've basically
identified the minimum so that's
Bayesian optimization in one dimension
and we can do all that with a with just
evaluating the function in point so it's
a we are optimizing without computing
gradients a little bit yes a little bit
about the one that we use you mean yeah
priors so in this type of models there's
a prior about the function that we're
trying to to optimize and and the prior
is encoded in terms of a kernel that
helps you define the Gaussian process
and this is where the smoothness
assumption comes from so you encode a
smoothness assumptions or other sorts of
assumptions in the kernel of the
Gaussian process and I mean it's it's
it's important that you have at least
some assumption because if the function
was totally wild like how am I ever
gonna pick the minimum find the minimum
with anything reasonable if there's no
smoothness
so so the algorithm that we designed to
find these pyretic runs we call it the
Pareto so it's it's in this case it's a
multi objective bayesian optimization
because we're trying to minimize two
objectives at the same time we're trying
to minimize the error and and minimize
the privacy loss and that's why we put
error instead of accuracy because then
we are minimizing both and if we try to
minimize one and maximize the other is
just yes yeah so in this case obviously
there's no minimum there's just the
upper at the front of minimums and and
the algorithm basically implements this
bayesian optimization loop like very
simply so we're given the hyper
parameter set we're given the privacy
and the error Oracle we just start by
picking some fixed number k0 of random
samples so we can bootstrap these models
so this is just like random points at
which we evaluate the privacy and the
error Oracle and we keep building a data
set by adding all the points that we
have observed so far so once we've
bootstrap the model we are going to do K
iterations and this is the the budget of
how many times you're willing to
evaluate your privacy and error Oracle's
that might involve training machine
learning model you're you're saying that
you're doing things that could be on the
fredo frontier ie are are the points
that your search algorithm found but in
fact you can randomize between any two
of those points and that's also an
available strategy and that's why you
should get a convex Pareto frontier but
I don't see why for example
interpolating not taking the average of
two hyper parameters is going to give me
the average utility or average privacy
that's the right way to think about it
you're not you're not constrained to use
on one they're constrained to get the
minimum error given privacy loss you
don't know which one ex-ante site but if
you know that apartment let's go to the
building wars between inside the private
sector is not going to be the average
but the way they're thinking it's all
nicely the edge between the whole stores
very sympathetic to this exercise that's
why I can't figure out why you don't
think the Pareto frontiers should be
come back I'll take it all off one okay
so and in this case when you're doing
multiple objectives like acquisition
functions get slightly trickier
it was Cynthia's question so in this
particular case we're using hyper volume
based probability of improvement which
is an acquisition function that tries to
do the following
so if so far I've found at the front
like this
so for each potential new hyper
parameter setting that I can try my
Gaussian process models will allow me to
predict where more or less this is gonna
fall in the in the error privacy law
space so the improvement then that you
get on the paleta front you can somehow
measure by by the volume that you're
adding to your Parata frontier so so
this type of acquisition functions and
there are several variations of this
type of acquisition functions for for
Parata frontiers
we'll try to find the next hyper
parameter point that will give you the
maximum improvement in terms of the
volume that you're adding to your
product frontier
so so let's let's see an example where
the part of largest not convex again
sorry
so so we wanted to have like probably
like some of something that's kind of
the simplest example where we can
illustrate what what's going on so we
modified the sparse vector technique a
little bit so it just has two hyper
parameters so here we have a sparse
vector technique that's Galactica data
set Z is it's not is more of a batch
type SBT so we have received M queries
and what we're gonna do is for each
query we're gonna evaluate it on the
date set we're gonna add some Laplace
noise we're gonna compare it to a noisy
threshold and we keep vector W that is
initially all zeroes and we're just
trying to find which of the queries are
gonna return one so here we're just
taking zero one valued queries and and
something that's slightly different from
the way you usually see sparse vector
technique is that here instead of the
hyper parameter being epsilon we have
hyper hyper parameters the amount of
noise and abound on the on the number of
ones that were willing to put in here
and then we split this noise like using
some formula that is in in in this
understanding SBT paper to minimize the
variance and and of course using in
terms of B and the number of things that
we're willing to answer there's a
formula that gives you the resulting
epsilon and what we want to do here is
is basically evaluate what settings of
these hyper parameters lead to optimal
privacy utility an optimal primacy
utility trade-off so the experiment that
we set up we set em to a hundred there's
a hundred sensitivity one queries and we
select so we randomly make it so that
them percent of them are half answer one
and and the others have answer zero so
the privacy Oracle here is just a close
close formula and the error that we
it is one - the F score which is the
harmonic mean of precision and recall in
terms of finding which queries return
one so this is not the standard a notion
of error but people have looked at when
analyzing the utility of the sparse
vector
technique but it's a nice cute little
number that gives you an idea of how
good you're recovering which queries
give you one so if you do that because
here we only have two hyper parameters
we can do an exhaustive search by
picking a very fine grid on on parameter
B and in parameter C and see what
Epsilon's are you getting and what is
the the error that you're getting and
here obviously the error needs to be
able with it empirically so we take an
average over 50 runs and using this
information you can compute the Pareto
front more or less in in closed form and
you get this Pareto frontier here and
here you can see what the inputs that
lead to different points like matching
the colors to plots so now that we have
this information which is kind of like
the almost exact Pareto frontier for
this algorithm we can try to see what
the Pareto does in this case so here I'm
showing you so what happens when we
initialize with 250 random randomly
sampled points so these maps here are
the results of the Gaussian process
trained on this is a random sample data
which starting to look very much like
the true error and privacy oracle's
and using these 250 sample points we
recover this empirical Pareto front that
is the black line here based on these
blue points in the error privacy space
and we see that that it's starting to
look very much like the true peretta
frontier and on top of that we can now
use these Gaussian processes to plot the
acquisition function and and see where
deeper at of things that it should
sample next and you
I don't know if you can see that but
there's two regions here that are
relatively empty in terms of the random
sampling and that could potentially give
us points in the in the Pareto front so
the point here we're not going to get
much in the Pareto front so the model
has to learn that and we have like a
region here where it's it would be
interesting to sample and there's
another region here and if you can see
in these plots but but well the point is
that the acquisition function decides to
sample here which is actually a point
that is trying to close this gap here in
the Pareto front so it's it's it's doing
what it's supposed to be doing so now a
remark to address with Kobe's question
was about whether the oracles leak might
leak privacy or the beretta frontman
leak privacy so when you're trying to do
this in practice you're going to have to
make like a lot of the F of this
implementation decisions so for a
privacy Oracle for example you can try
to like get absolute for fixed Delta you
could also try to use other variants of
differential privacy
you could even consider some other
attacks like membership in friends at
tags or reconstruction attacks and and
do the success metric as your privacy
Oracle in there on top of that you might
have whichever thing you pick in here
you might have it available in close
form or you might have to do some
numerical calculation like the moments
accountant and and that's what we're
gonna do next in in some machine
learning experiments in terms of the
error Oracle you can also think of a lot
of alternative definitions so you could
think what is the error for a fixed
input you could think what is the error
for a distribution over input or
worst-case over a set of inputs you can
also try to have error expectation with
high probability and you I mean it would
be really nice if you had the exact
expressions for their Oracle but that's
I think that that's very unlikely in
most cases so you can rely on empirical
evaluations so these are the the choices
that we make
in our machine learning experiments and
indeed because we are evaluating the
error Oracle on a fixed input which
means that I mean in this case means
that we're training on a fixed date set
and then we're reporting the error on a
holdout set but that we're gonna reuse
every time we call the error Oracle and
and we do like several repetitions
because there's randomness introduced by
differential privacy the values returned
by the error Oracle might be leaking
some privacy so we didn't try to address
this explicitly yet there's several like
solutions you can come up with from the
solution 0 which is let's ignore that
issue you could try to perform this
privacy utility exploration on a public
data set that is already released and
that you know that is kind of like
follows a similar distribution to to the
one that that you want to train your
data on which is the pate type approach
or you could privatized evaluations of
the error Oracle but then you're gonna
you will have to make peace with the
fact that your your Pareto front has
additional sources of noise so your
decisions might be less reliable let's
see
so in terms of machine learning
experiments we work with - they'd set
the audible data set and the omni's data
set and we tried a couple of things so
for the adult data set we try to
logistic regression with two different
optimizers linear SVM with an SGD
optimizer and we recovered this pirata
front here that although obviously
they're they're noisy they're based on
16 bootstrap points of random sampling
plus 256 iterations of the Bayesian
optimization loop we're starting to see
to see interesting things like for
example it seems like SVM is not that
good in this regime of epsilon for
example logistic regression and for
example Adam might be doing a better job
in the high privacy regime at finding
well not like blowing up the oculus
immediately when you go to that regime
for the emmys data set we tried just
stochastic gradient descent on two
different architectures deep learning
architectures they're not very deep so
one just is a multi-layer perceptron
with one hidden layer with a thousand
units and the other is has two hidden
layers one with 128 units and you have
64 and and and this is the plot that I
showed you at the beginning which which
seems to say that well if you are in the
in the high privacy regime axial more
than one both architectures seem to be
doing the same but as you move closer to
say epsilon 0.1 the architecture that
has less hidden units is actually doing
better than than the architecture that
might be too big for this problem
the other type of experiments that we
did are about making sure that this
makes sense in in the sense of comparing
the Pareto so the Bayesian optimization
against some simple baseline strategy
which is random sampling so what happens
if instead of trying to do this very
fancy thing of picking the points using
an acquisition function based on on
Gaussian processes train on the point
we've seen so far we just go and do some
random sampling obviously random
sampling is quite good it's eventually
gonna find very good peretta fronts but
it's gonna take you many many more
evaluations right so so here there's
three different things to see the same
phenomenon so here for example in the
case of logistic regression with SGD we
have the Pareto front learned by de
Pareto with 256 iterations of the
Bayesian optimization loop versus 1500
random sample points and and the two
part of run just start to look very much
when when you have these difference in
the order of magnitude but it's
interesting to see that the the Pareto
is is always trying to sample things
that are very close to the Pareto front
whereas random sampling is a little bit
all over the place so so these Gaussian
processes are learning what they're
supposed to be learning another way to
see the same phenomenon is here for
example where in in this MLP to model
here we have the the Pareto front that
we obtain with these 16 initial random
samples and then we can add the same
number of additional points either be a
random sampling sampling that gives you
the spread of front or with Bayesian
optimization that does a much better job
at finding how you tune the hyper
parameters to move into into the low
privacy regime and the third plot is is
kind of illustrating the same with
another type of measure a measure of how
the hypervolume
improves as you increase the number of
points either with rather sampling or
Bayesian optimization
okay so I'm just getting to the
conclusion I think that pinnacle privacy
utility trade of evaluations are very
important to enable application specific
decisions like this idea of how you for
example should choose an architecture
for machine learning or an optimizer if
you want to like balance the privacy
utility trade-off and and and our
results show that Bayesian optimization
seems to provide the computationally
efficient method at least when you
compare it to random sampling to recover
this predator front and this is
especially useful when you're hyper
parameter space is very large and here
large five five parameters is already
quite large right because this like the
size of a potential grid search would
grow exponentially with with the number
of hyper parameters so in future work we
would like to see what is the best way
to address the leakage in in this
peretta fronts coming from the error
Oracle when when it's evaluated on on
specific inputs and and we would also
like to explore other things like
introducing further criteria in the
optimization for example running time so
you might have additional trade-offs
between running time accuracy and
privacy and and this kind this kind of
framework allows you to also introduce
other criteria so if you have any other
criteria that you think would be
interesting to explore here I would love
to hear about it and that's all thanks
[Applause]
give others what is that actual data
when it goes from one point zero three
0.85 or so the first the first chunk
your goal this chunk no so so here no so
so here I'm just signaling that III
never so so this way it might be more
productive for you to draw out the other
way so that the economics of this is
that if that is actually the frayed of
protein or starting with the first real
point not with the zero one point that's
the first actual point that you got then
what it means is that the technology
you're trying to implement it has a
region of increasing returns in epsilon
so that means the decision problem that
you're implicitly posing here it's not
going to be well behaved because if I
met my preferences over error and
epsilon and they have classic preference
characteristics there's going to be two
or more points that intersect with the
Pareto frontier instead of being tangent
with the planar frontier
so there'll be interesting situations
where I might take a massive amount of
inaccuracy because I took a very very
small epsilon or a much larger more
accurate epsilon that a preference in
different this increasing returns to
scale those things usually cause the
real decision problem which is this is
the choice set what my preferences are
come from other things from the Social
Welfare function to get very very
difficult to give a good answer to well
we have found what we end up the
strategy that we try to use public data
evaluation but are the ones that you
drew a picture of for example you stole
from all my presentations that was
public data mining
as you increase epsilon all of these
well implemented algorithms get you back
to the truth so there's a region of
what's decreasing returns to scale in
economics terms which is what gives you
the convexity of the Pareto frontier
that is built into any algorithm that
has the property that when you give it
an infinite privacy lost budget you get
back the truth okay yeah so that's why
it should be convex because it
eventually has to be convex but I was I
was I thought that that region of non
convexity that you had there was due to
actually having evaluations that were
between the 0.85 and one over that's
just you just drew that line in that's
not the first real evaluation this is
yeah well if you can complete it we just
have he was doing it by example that it
wasn't clear where that increasing
returns to scale and generalize but now
it's clear to smooth that office this
procedure has a region of increasing
returns which makes the decision problem
about epsilon and accuracy much more
difficult because standard preferences
will give you multiple solutions in
these kinds of technologies that's
interesting yet itself so that's why I
was trying to understand why he was
showing non convex part portion of the
Braille frontier this is only half the
choice from the other every choice
problem does you have to extract your
preferences over epsilon and the
classification area which is not covered
by you know no and we're not trying to
cover like that no that's a policy or a
business question
[Applause]